I'm Dr Neville sanjana human geneticist
today I'll be taking your questions from
Twitter this is genetic support
[Music]
at sort of known o as someone explained
Lenny Kravitz to me please I'd like to
understand how his genes work how is he
still this hot I'm not sure there's a
gene for hot but most complex traits are
not due to just one gene they're due to
many genes all of us inherit part of our
genome from our mom and part of our
genome from our dad and Lenny Kravitz
has a pretty diverse ancestry he has
Russian Jewish ancestry from his
father's side he has afro-caribbean
ancestry from his mother's side the
genes that control our immune system are
amongst the most variable genes in the
human genome maybe the secret to Lenny's
youthfulness is that he inherited a
diverse set of immune genes and no
traffic in La asks can they DNA test
ashes unfortunately no DNA breaks down
at temperatures above 400 degrees
Fahrenheit and cremation happens at very
high temperatures like 1500 degrees or
2000 degrees Fahrenheit but at ambient
temperature the story is different DNA
is very stable in fact the the Nobel
Prize in 2022 was given out to svante
pebo for sequencing and reconstructing
the Genome of a neanderthal at CIS sex
serve as I personally find it hard to
believe that all human beings who have
blue eyes are descendants of one human
being who had a genetic mutation all
current evidence points to an event
about six thousand to ten thousand years
ago that resulted in a mutation in a
gene called oca2 oca2 is responsible for
a protein called melanin in our eyes
that mutation occurred in Europe and all
blue eyed people today are distantly
related to that founder from 10 000
years ago but it's not the only Gene
that's important for eye color there are
about eight genes that we know about
that contribute to eye color in humans
and even if you have the brown eyes
version of oca2 sometimes you can end up
with blue eyes and that's due to the
contributions from those seven other
genes at vandan LeBron asks how does
23andMe work is it a scam well it's not
a scam in fact 23andMe does a lot of
basic genetics Research In addition to
testing your DNA here are two flow cells
from an aluminous sequencer these can
sequence hundreds of human genomes in a
single day we flow in the DNA it binds
to this glass slide and then the
sequencer acts like a very powerful
microscope that can image the DNA but
sequencing costs a lot it can cost about
a thousand dollars to sequence a whole
Human Genome so how does 23andMe do it
for only a hundred dollars the secret is
that they only sequence a small portion
of the genome maybe 1 100 of one percent
of the six billion bases of the human
genome and even those half million bases
can tell us a lot about ancestry and
specific traits you might have so they
compare your genome to people from
Scotland or people from Brazil and
that's how they can tell what percent of
you comes from here or what percent of
you comes from there at Mother Nature
God s but why do genes mutate at all
genes can recombine in ways that
introduce genetic diversity some
stations can give us stronger bones they
can protect against heart disease or
protect against severe covet if this
diversity didn't happen at each
generation we'd be like bananas modern
bananas are all clones of each other 80
years ago all bananas were a different
clone the grow Michelle clone and then a
fungal infection came and wiped out the
entire population why because there is
no genetic diversity so now let's talk
about the bad mutations the disease that
comes to mind here is cancer cancer
arises from somatic mutations those are
the mutations you're not born with but
that arise later in life they're acting
out of line and start growing in ways
that we don't expect and don't want that
shitty questions asked how does Sun
affect your DNA well I have two words
for you wear sunscreen UV can be a very
very powerful mutagen for DNA and what
it does specifically is these sea bases
these green bases it can turn them into
T bases these red bases now if this
happens most these mutations they don't
do anything it's not not very harmful if
it happens in certain genes that are
important in cancer like oncogenes or
tumor suppressor genes it can create
deadly cancers like skin cancer that's
why you should wear sunscreen at Michael
Kai asks God why do my genes have to
make me five one I'm so short well
height is truly an amazing trait because
it's super polygenic that means many
many different places in the genome
contribute to height we think that we
can explain about 50 percent of the
contributions to height based on genes
alone but what about the other 50 well
that probably has something to do with
the environment you grew up in the foods
you ate things like that at eee lemon's
ass guys quick how are DNA and genes
related DNA is the letters that make up
genes A T C and G when we arrange those
letters in very specific ways we can
write longer words and those words are
the genes but they're not just arranged
randomly they're actually arranged like
chapters in a book each one on a
different chromosome if chromosomes are
like chapters in a book the human genome
is the whole book everything that makes
you you at cosine distance as Alexa am I
related to Genghis Khan maybe they're
estimates that 1 in 200 men living today
carry a very similar Y chromosome which
indicates a recent common ancestor all
men inherit the Y chromosome not from
Mom and Dad but just from their Dads
Moms don't have a y chromosome and
Genghis Khan he lived about 800 years
ago so the math fits it's possible that
about 0.5 percent of the men living
today inherited their Y chromosome from
a recent common ancestor maybe Genghis
Khan at Nino clutch asks Spider-Man is
so raw maybe we should try that DNA
biotech cross gene splicing well I'm not
sure we're going to see Spider-Man
anytime soon but there is a lot of
interest from biotech companies and
academic labs to understand spider silk
which is five times stronger than steel
spider silk is very biocompatible very
good for wound healing especially for
wounds of the eye and the brain and
there's been many efforts to engineer
spider silk outside of spiders to make
it in a recombinant way meaning not in
spiders but in other organisms like
bacteria or plants probably the best
known example of a recombinant protein
is insulin this has helped millions of
people across the last four decades
since the first insulin was produced in
bacteria at someone Googled asked how
does crispr work step by step well
crispr is not the thing in your fridge
when we talk about crispr especially in
terms of medicine we're normally talking
about a protein called cas9 cas9 comes
from bacterial genomes but we as genome
Engineers have taken it and repurposed
it for uses in the lab and for genetic
medicine the first step for crispr is to
tell it where to go in the genome and
the way that we program the common
crisprands on cas9 is that we give it a
little piece of RNA that matches the DNA
in the genome and so cas9 can surf along
the genes the DNA bases in the genome
until it finds the perfect match for its
guide RNA once it finds that match then
it knows where to make the cut and you
can think of cas9 like a pair of
scissors it just Snips at a specific
location in the DNA once it makes that
cut we can provide a template to
precisely repair the DNA and correct a
mutation for muscular dystrophy sickle
cell anemia or any of the other
thousands of inborn genetic diseases at
David
[Music]
y193-9661 asks a question from a Layman
as there are DNA strands in every one of
our billions of cells how can editing
one strand in Vivo presumably in a
single cell extend to the DNA in all
other cells for a question from a Layman
I'm impressed with the use of in Vivo
there is so much DNA in our cells in
just one cell there there's about seven
feet of DNA if you took that balled up
DNA in the nucleus and stretched it out
there's about 30 trillion cells so if
you multiply that out you get 40 billion
miles of DNA that's enough to go from
the Earth to the Sun a few hundred times
so how does editing one cell impact
other cells we normally want to edit
stem cells like blood stem cells or
muscle stem cells and that's because
those cells have the most potential to
divide so when you edit the Genome of
those cells it can replenish other cells
it can make other cells once that edit
is made all the cells all the daughter
cells all the descendants of that stem
cell get the same edit in their DNA at
symbol J asks could crispr technology be
used to fix all the people who don't
like cilantro it's true there are some
people have a specific genetic variant
that causes cilantro to taste like soap
even if crispr could fix the people I
don't think this is the best use of the
technology there are very serious
diseases where we already know crispr
can make a huge difference these are
diseases like sickle cell anemia or beta
thalassemia the people who suffer from
these diseases they really aren't great
treatments for them but with crispr
we've already shown work from our group
and many other groups that we can
reverse on these diseases even cure them
by taking out blood cells from these
patients editing them and then putting
them back so I think when we think as
genome Engineers about what should we
work on it's really about these genetic
diseases that's where the initial focus
of the field is going to be at nilly LOL
asks how the F does DNA replication work
well DNA replication is one of the most
beautiful things in biology so every
time your gut regenerates or a new layer
of skin cells comes about those cells
need a full copy of the human genome and
every time you make a new cell you make
a new genome one way to visualize how
this happens is to take a double helix
and see how the two halves of the Helix
come apart right here in the middle when
DNA replicates the double helix comes
apart and each half helix has enough
information to make a whole new double
helix the DNA polymerase which is what
makes new DNA comes in and sees these
bases and can synthesize the pairs to
them so T pairs with a and g pairs with
C and that way a whole new Helix can be
made from just a half Helix at Cody
heberden asks is alcoholism genetic
sometimes alcoholism runs in families
but that doesn't mean it's genetic
they've been genome-wide Association
studies that have tried to figure out
how much of the contribution to
alcoholism comes from our genes it seems
to be somewhere between 40 and 60
percent there are also genetic variants
that are associated with the opposite of
alcoholism so there's some people of
Asian descent that don't tend to drink
and that's because when they do drink
their face becomes flush they become a
little bit nauseous they don't have the
ability to metabolize the the alcohol so
it instantly makes them feel a little
bit sick and in those folks with those
variants there are very very low rates
of alcoholism they seem to be protected
against the disease at phony horse asks
how many times science is going to
announce that they've mapped the human
genome I feel like I see that same
headline every few years well you're not
alone in reality there's been several
different achievements of genome mapping
20 years ago on the White House lawn
they announced the first draft Human
Genome we knew for the first time how
many genes there were in the human
genome 20 000 genes but that genome had
thousands of gaps it was only 90 percent
complete a couple years later they
announced a more complete genome where
they only had about 400 gaps last year
2022 scientists had a truly gapless
genome they called it telomere to
telomere telomeres are the ends of the
chromosomes meaning that they had the
complete sequence from one end to the
other end of the chromosome but we're
not done yet now we need to sequence
more genomes from diverse populations
because it's not just about getting the
letters A's T C's and G's it's about
understanding really what they mean so I
hate to break it to you but you're going
to see this headline a few more times
over the next five ten years at Lynn the
Allen writes does our DNA change the
genome that we're born with is more or
less the genome we have at the end of
our lives but that doesn't mean it
doesn't change certainly we accumulate
mutations over time but in addition to
the primary sequence of DNA in addition
to the A's T C's and G's there's our
epigenome the epigenome is kind of like
Plato on the genome it can control what
parts of the genome are more likely to
be seen and which parts remain hidden
and that epigenome is constantly
changing it's changing over time and it
changes over different organs so even
though your genome is the same over time
other things that are interacting with
your genome are changing quite a bit at
its McKenzie Ms could crispr cas9 help
those who are highly susceptible to
cancer reduce their risk like those who
could possess mutated tumor suppressor
genes I don't think crispr's really
being considered so much for editing
cancers themselves but it's certainly
being used to build better cancer
therapies one thing that my lab works on
is using crispr to engineer immune cells
taking cells like T cells from cancer
patients and training them making them
better fighters of those cancers making
them less likely to give up when they
encounter the terrible environment of
the tumor so we can take those blood
cells like T cells out of a patient we
can edit them with crispr in the lab and
put them back in the patient and not
only have can we eliminate the cancer in
some cases but we can install a security
system that then is with them for the
rest of their life at Nat harunias what
if we could crispr people to be a little
more resistant to radiation less
dependent on food and oxygen sounds like
it would benefit us on Mars I get this
type of question a lot it assumes that
we know a lot more about human genetics
than we actually do I think a much more
serious and important question is the
ethical one really should we do this and
the consensus in the field really is
that traits that are about enhancement
you know things that you know might be
nice are really probably not where the
field of genome editing should focus its
efforts on serious genetic diseases are
really the current focus of the field so
those are all the questions for today
thanks for watching genetic support
[Music]